each plant has a story like that each
plant has something positive that it
wants to bring to your health every
single one wants to bring something to
your health and if we overemphasize the
superfoods we can you know I could eat
kale all day and I'll have vitamin K
dripping out of my eyeballs way more
than my body needs but I'll make myself
deficient in other things because I'll
be over emphasizing certain things and
I'll be missing out on the other
opportunities I personally would rather
take 10 mediocre plants and put that in
my diet than one superfood I mean I
honestly think that the diversity
because you play off of the strengths of
all of them and when you have that you
get all of the amino acids you get all
the different types of fiber to feed
your microbiome you get all the
different phytochemicals you just can't
get it done with one plant there's no
perfect plant